châtaignes ce qui est chouette c'est
qu'elles se marient justement aussi avec
les dernières tomates les tomates vertes
la scène pour lesquelles on ne sait pas
faire grand chose avec et finalement va
là on va aller chercher justement cette
acidité
donc là on va faire des gnocchis à la
châtaigne on va voir ce côté moelleux à
peu gourmand et on va le travail est
justement avec le lièvre à la royale
les châtaignes et les pommes de terre
ont été blanchis que les et cuite sur du
gros sel histoire d'enlever toute
humilité
elles sont prêtes pour le passage au
tamis moulin à légumes
ce qu'il faut en fait c'est vraiment
sécher la pulpe a rapporté d'humidité
justement dans les nautiques fait
d'étape qui exige le plus de patients
objectif 125 grammes de pulpe de
châtaignes et 62 g de pommes de terre la
cuisine deux étoiles c'est très précis
reste à ajouter le demi jaune d'oeuf et
la paris pour un premier round
entre les lignes on qui commencent à
remonter ses écrits vont commencer et au
bout d'une minute on peut les sortir
on a préparé de l'eau avec des glaçons
il faut tout de suite et glacée pour
bloquer justement les gnocchis donc là
on les sort délicatement on les plonge
dans l'eau glacée on va les laisser
refroidir et ensuite on va pouvoir les
préparés en cuisine où justement on a
énormément de production de châtaignes
dans la région c'est celle de sologne
on aime les valoriser on aime aussi
aller les chercher parce que je trouve
que c'est
voilà un moment aussi de nature un
moment où on s'évade de la cuisine donc
on adore ça après un petit glaçage au
beurre et à l'eau voici les gnocchis à
la châtaigne prêt à être dressé en fait
ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment jouer sur
les textures en fait c'est ça qui est
important
féticheur en petite taille âge regardez
up les petits cubes de châtaignes
également associé au lièvre à la royale
est agrémenté d'une petite touche de
truffes le new qui est la châtaigne
façon christophe et devient un plat de
fête